it's always good to talk with you before
we even get into the NBA free agency
stuff I was asked a question yesterday
but I want to ask you the exact same
question and it was from the the PMT
guys can you rank the Dan Nets for me
Chris ah well let's see I mean Ollie is
my Vermont neighbor but he's he's on my
my my blacklist as of today I would
probably say Fritzi uh Perloff seaton
than poli just because Seaton continues
to record all of my my my awful takes I
think first of all random back down I
mean our team with yeah there it is Seth
now and so I would I would say that
that's the case so why is pulling on
your blacklist uh he knows it's it's a
personal decision that I've made I'm not
talking to paulie for at least a month
and yeah I'm just gonna go that I'm just
going to leave at that got it alright so
I want to get into before we even
getting into free agency stuff I want to
get your thoughts on the Chris Paul deal
with the Houston Rockets and I know
everybody's talked about this I'm not
sure I really understand it every time I
watch both the Clippers and the Rockets
you know Harden and Paul have the ball
all the time it almost feels like I know
it's not directly related to football
but it almost feels like it got two
quarterbacks now how's that gonna work
well I mean it's a good problem to have
if you look at at what the Rockets were
last year James Harden was both their
primary scorer and he was their primary
playmaker and that took a big toll on
Harvey during the regular season so much
so that when you watched him against San
Antonio in the playoffs and he didn't
have any help facilitating that was a
big reason I thought San Antonio bowed
out remember they lost Game six on their
home floor went in the game without
Kawhi Leonard playing for the other side
so that was a lot of that had to do I
think with the fact that hearkens had
too much response
with the ball now you have bring Chris
Paul submit another top five playmaker
in this league and you can spread the
wealth a little bit now I don't deny
Ross but there'll be an adjustment
period
with this group I don't think it'll be I
hope they'll get off to the fastest
starts but when you have these two guys
and their skill sets and Mike D'Antoni
who is brilliant at devising offensive
schemes for wing players I think by
midseason they're going to look like one
of the best backcourts of basketball
there's been so much said about it Chris
but I wanted to get your thoughts and
what you've been hearing on why Chris
Paul Baek Hyun and maybe along with that
why he left LA well I think that look a
lot of stuff that's been out there is is
true the friction with Doc Rivers with
something a lot of people in the league
knew about all year the friction with
Blake Griffin was very real you know I
talked to people that work for the team
and that played you know former
teammates that had told me that they
would have been shocked if Chris Paul
came back if Blake Griffin was there now
now they didn't have that directly from
Chris but they were just using that
based on their observations of what they
saw so you know there was there was some
truth to what's out there about the
discord with Chris and the theme that
being said I think this was more about a
desire to play with James Harden than it
was anything else
you know these two guys have been
all-star teammates
they've been USA basketball teammates
they didn't just hatch this plan the
last couple of weeks this is probably
something that's been going on for
months if not years in at least
conversations and I think Harden saw a
better opportunity to maximize his
championship window playing alongside a
guy who is arguably the best player in
the game Chris should we care about the
nitty gritty details I mean I just feel
like I guess this happens in the NFL at
times as well but it almost feels like
with this well you know it was because
of his son he treated his son
differently and maybe that's just you
know sports now and that's what we
talked about but on some level it almost
feels like we're going
I'm back and like I feel like we're like
junior high Junior High girls yeah I
mean it's there's a melodrama in the NBA
that is that has swallowed up a lot of
the narratives out there I mean whether
it's LeBron and we wants to coach him or
you know play players and LaMarcus
Aldridge you like playing with Kawhi
Leonard I mean everything is it more
stuff as often about off the court that
it is on and that's the same thing
that's true with the Clippers right now
now the author River stuff I'm not sure
I altogether maybe that the reporting
out there is that there was some offer
on the table from the Clippers that they
could have made with the Knicks for
Carmelo Anthony that would have involved
Austin Rivers I mean that was that that
was never real you know Carmelo Anthony
was never going to the Clippers for this
you know Austin Rivers
you know bass you know Austin Rivers
headline you know basically bag of spare
parts out there wasn't it wasn't close
to coming to fruition
between those two teams so that part of
it I don't I don't buy but look you know
Chris played there six years he played
for Doc Rivers for a long time
you know sometimes teammates you know
this as a former player sometimes I just
don't get along and Chris was looking at
this stage was career for for something
different for Houston though quickly on
that I mean you know this is this is a
big deal but it's a big risk I mean
they're probably going to pay Chris Paul
you know four years max dollars at the
in his next contract and they'll
probably be paying a 37 38 year old
point guard 40-plus million dollars on
the back end of his deal and as great of
a players Chris Paul is right now I
can't imagine worth that money at that
age of a part of his career talking with
Chris Mannix from Yahoo Sports the
vertical what's the first free agent
Domino Chris is it does it dig it works
that way that we got to wait for Hayward
or we got to wait to see what happens to
Paul George and then this will happen
how do you think the Domino's play out
over the next couple days weeks whatever
well I think with Gordon Hayward its
Gordon Hayward the first guy to go
Gordon Hayward
is is the marquee guys going to be
chased by Miami Boston and Utah a lot of
dominoes fall immediately after that you
know Paul George could be del face of
what Boston has less to offer could be
dealt any way to Boston if they ramp
they're out there price not to go and
get him and other teams I think we'll
will act accordingly so I would put
Gordon Hayward at the compet list but he
may not be the first guy to sign you
know Gordon Haywood set up interviews
already over the first few days of free
agency and when he does that you might
take a day or two after those meetings
to make a decision I mean he's always
struck me and people across the league
as a guy that's really going to agonize
over this if he decides to leave Utah
it's not going to be an easy decision
for this guy he made it ultimately
decide on Boston but it could be an
agonizing decision but I think he's the
guy that leads to the next you know the
next series of deals that would happen
across the league and then who's that
what what is it what's two three four
you think most likely so I mean if Blake
Griffin is still unsigned you know the
teams that lose out on Gord Haywood will
ramp up their efforts to get there you
know I I still believe that Chris Paul
leaving makes it far more likely the
Blake Griffin stays in Los Angeles
especially if they pony up a five-year
deal at at you know whatever it is
hundred sixty seventy million dollars
over the lifetime of it that's real
money for God's man injury-prone over
the last few years and he would be the
man with that team it would be his
franchise now it would take some
rebuilding and maybe they have to part
ways with DeAndre Jordan via trade to
upgrade the roster but the idea of
having his own team in LA I I do think
that matters the Blake Griffin what
about the Knicks you know for whatever
reason and there are teams like this in
the NFL Chris that we just always have
to talk about them and the latest are
these rumors with John Calipari what do
you think ends up happening with the
Knicks goes from a front office
standpoint and personnel well I mean
Calipari likes to be flirted with he
likes his name in the mix because it
only helps him it makes Kentucky more
eager to keep him it could mean more
money in a new deal from Kentucky and
anytime you hear Calipari same
associated with the NBA recruit see that
and and they they want to be associated
with the NBA they're going to Kentucky
not for a three or four year education
they're going for help getting to the
next level and Calipari being attractive
to NBA teams
does that I don't see I mean James
Dolan's kind of crazy but I don't know
that the knick owner would make that
type of deal to bring Calipari to New
York not after Phil Jackson's the
absolute he has to hire a real
basketball guy at this point now
skeptically gets Toronto's society Rhee
but I do think that David Griffin
the former Cavaliers president is a real
option here Griffin it worked relatively
cheaply in Cleveland over the last three
years has a good track record and if you
get back into the game these factors if
they look like they have a good working
relationship I think that could work out
Chris house the NBA's popularity right
now it feels like we talked about it
more people are more into it especially
in the offseason
you know when free agency starts and the
Chris Paul deal and everything that's
going on but during the season I don't
feel like there's as much buzz and
obviously a lot of teams seemingly have
no shot right from the start
overall how is the health of the game in
this sort of superstar super team era
that we're in well I mean the NBA will
be the first to tell you that they would
love to have NFL style parity they would
love every postseason to begin with six
or seven games realistically thinking
that they have a chance to win a
championship that's not the case right
now and that's not going to be the case
probably for least in the next three or
four years as long as Golden State keeps
that team together but look the NBA it
has the best offseason in sports it owns
the offseason activities from you know
the draft and the speculation there to
free-agency into summer league you know
sports in the NFL as a better offseason
than the NBA s they've done a masterful
job as making their sport basically a
ten and a half to 11 months per year
type of league and that's good for that
for the health of it but as long as
there's there's these super teams out
there it's going to hurt local TV
ratings it's going to hurt overall play
operating about the finals but overall
playoff ratings it's going to be a net
negative for the NBA they know it
there's just nothing right now they can
do about it any surprises you see coming
over the next couple weeks Chris I was
always something and you know I'm
keeping an eye on San Antonio
they convinced consult opted out of his
contract to leave sixteen million
dollars on the table to maintain some
flexibility in signing a free agent I
think San Antonio could be in play for
Kyle Lowry the Toronto Raptors guard
that mean Lowry can make the most money
in Toronto is basically worshiped up
there and that or that franchise is not
afraid to spend money because they have
a lot of it
with that group but you know San Antonio
is lurking and if I'm a guy like Kyle
Lowry I'm 31 years old this is probably
my last big contract my last chance to
win a ring he just got broomed out of
the playoffs with his best overall team
by the Cavaliers and and look that's
that's going to be sitting in the back
of his mind I go back to Toronto collect
a big cheque or I could take a little
less money go to San Antonio and and see
what I can do with the Spurs for the
next few years so that's the team in the
situation I think it's the most fluid
right now Chris thanks for the time as
always men a time for us all right check
him out on Yahoo Sports the vertical
awesome awesome breakdown by Mannix as
usual the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience